- Are you excited though,
about Halloween this weekend?
Do you dress up?
- I, yes. I mean, I have three kids
so my kids are like 12, 10, and eight.
So they're into it very much, so -
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Joey] There they are.
- Yeah! Oh, we love carving
pumpkins at our house.
It's a thing.
- And that's Roxy.
She's a little baby underneath the table.
Yeah, I mean, it's going
to be funky this year
because, you know, you have to make it
as festive as possible in the house.
So, we try to decorate,
and the front yard's
nice and spooky and all that stuff.
- Yeah, I know.
We're doing like a whole scavenger hunt
with my kids just at my house.
Just, like, so they can...
They're four and six so
they don't really understand
why they can't go out,
and they are really tired of the sickness.
That's what we call it.
They're like, is the sickness over yet?
And we're like, almost honey.
- The sickness was different in my house.
This is a different sickness.
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, people must have dressed
up as NKO TV all the time
back in the day, right?
- They were, you know, if...
You needed some essentials.
You needed holes in your jeans and vests.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And vests.
- Everybody had vests.
Get a vest, you know?
Yeah, we have the most
amazing fans and we've,
we very much embrace the past.
- Yeah.
- So, we've kind of brought that look back
often over the years, as you can see
Well, that was, see I
can't even, so that was
a few years ago, to say the least.
But we've, you know, we take
the piss out of ourselves
and put those outfits back on and -
- I love it, though.
And here's the thing.
What's needed now more than
ever is nostalgia, too.
Like any kind of hopeful, like fun,
like, I don't know, escapism.
Like it's, I think it's needed right now.
- Like coming on "The Kelly
Clarkson Show?" I mean -
- Yes, exactly. This feels good to me.
- I mean, thank you! I'm out of the house!
- [Kelly] Feels good to me.